in an increasing culture where we have
shorter form things and I'm I wonder how
that's you know working for you and do
you always want to write long books or
how does that work it's it's what I do
it's not it's not a matter of wanting to
necessarily but it's I think you know I
my observation is that first of all
there's plenty of long books that appear
to do quite well and end up on
bestseller lists and get adapted into TV
shows and movies so so clearly there is
a market for for great big long books
and I think the people who who read them
enjoy the sort of indulgence of Total
Immersion prolonged immersion in a big
complicated world and I think that
explains why long-form television has
become you know overwhelmingly popular
and successful medium in the last I
don't know 10 years or so is precisely
because people kind of revel in the
opportunity to get lost in a great big
fictional universe and the more that we
become like the the land of tweet
Twitter
the more that there is this sort of
broke that a didi is sort of celebrated
and and found useful the more we need
the long-form stuff to about
counterbalance that I think yeah I mean
we also see you know podcasts obviously
that can be hours long that are becoming
more popular not less popular so there
seems to be some divergent set of form
humans are wired to want that to get
through the long winter nights and so on
and that and that that's in a way just
something inside of us is craving that
enough that culturally were returning
we're moving in that direction while
we're also going in the other direction
to balance it out
[Music]
you